foreign it starts with an irritable Buzz
distant but seemingly harmless
but the volume grows as it descends from
the sky
its dark triangular shape generating
Terror on the streets of Kiev
some people fled hunting for cover
others stopped and held their ground
it's flying it's flying shoot it
immediately says one
here it is shoot shoot
it's the second time in seven days that
the Ukrainian Capital has been targeted
in massive airstrikes the Russians
sending dozens of so-called suicide
drones into the very Heart of the City
[Music]
lacking sophisticated Weaponry for air
defense members of the Ukrainian Highway
Patrol used their machine guns and their
pistols instead
incredibly perhaps these officers say
they managed to shoot the Drone down
and government officials say the vast
majority of these weapons failed to
reach their target 85 percent shot out
of the sky
the Russian military said it was
targeting energy infrastructure but one
drone hit a residential building tearing
a hole in the side
four bodies have been recovered here
including a couple called Bogdan and
Victoria who was six months pregnant
with the couple's child
that according to the mayor of Kiev who
accused the Russians of terrorism
it is a terrorist attack I don't have
another term it is a genocide by
Russians they are fighting civilians
they are destroying the critical
infrastructure of our city and killing
innocent people some spent the day below
the surface in shelters and underground
train stations While others try to get
on with their lives
but this Airborne threat hangs over them
all yeah
so how do I feel I'm full of Rage I'm so
full of rage and hate for those
two-legged creatures
the ukrainians say these suicide drones
were made for Russia in Iran
but this Sinister barrage is unlikely to
break their spirit
John Sparks Sky News in Ukraine